a life hangs in the balance
a harsh of an operating theater a
Ukrainian surgical team operates on a
woman's heart
if all goes well she'll live many more
years
but Ukraine is a country under attack
assuming the best is something people
hear no longer do
performing any surgery is difficult
enough but imagine doing this knowing
that at any time a Russian airstrike
could plunge the operating room the
whole Hospital Into Darkness that's
exactly what happened on November 23rd
this video was filmed by the chief
surgeon
a 14 year old boy is in the middle of an
operation when Russian missiles take
down the power
system
[Music]
I promise
now let's see
it's a glimpse of what happens when
civilian Power Systems are attacked
by good luck and the care of Ukraine's
best heart team the boy made it through
we caught up with David just before he
was discharged home
I feel gratitude first of all to God to
the doctors
and they feel Joy that all went well
this is a miracle for sure
David's mom is still recovering too
when the explosion started and the
lights went off two feelings started to
grow first appreciation for the doctors
working in insecure conditions they
didn't stop the second was Rage which
isn't inherent in me because why what
for our country is suffering our
children are suffering constantly in
danger
Paris todorov performed Ukraine's first
ever heart transplant and leads the
country's Heart Institute it's ready for
the next airstrikes
we made large supplies of blood plasma
food and water fitted all our equipment
with batteries so they can work for
several hours then after 15 minutes the
generators are turned on and so we've
created a completely autonomous system
like on a submarine
[Music]
like David Ukraine is battered bruised
but winning the fight for its survival
the boy his mom and dad are leaving kiev
for their Hometown what they find when
they get there will depend on Russia and
its missiles
Rory challenge Al Jazeera Kiev